[Music]
hey we've teamed up with a company
called the dream world to bring our
anime merch store to the next level
check us out at anime out Broadcom for
exclusive designs including some
brand-new ones dots anime upper calm or
click the link in the description hey
what is up everybody its Anna Mak here
for anime uproar and today I will be
breaking down the very latest
developments in the seven deadly sins
story last week I didn't make a video
because I didn't think that chapter 3
for one gave me enough material to go on
for a full video but with the release of
chapter three for two we definitely have
a lot to talk about
also we have some potentially huge news
about the manga some news outlets are
reporting that the seven deadly sins
manga will be ending with volume 41 of
the story volume 41 is set to be
released in May of this year so if this
claim is true it means that as of the
publication of this video we only have
about four or five chapters to go before
the end of the entire series but is this
possible could the manga really be
ending so soon and if so what kind of
ending are we talking about the brand
new chaos arc has seemingly just started
so does this mean that we're looking at
a rushed and unsatisfying ending or is
naka bouzouki just trolling us again I
will talk about all of that and a lot
more right here in this video if you
enjoyed the seven deadly sins content on
the channel and you want us to keep it
going please leave a like to let me know
it really helps and if you have it to be
new to the channel or you just didn't
subscribe yet please consider
subscribing and hitting that
notification bell if you really want to
be notified the next time we upload
another seven deadly sins video and you
don't want YouTube to bury our videos
you have to go through the trouble of
clicking the notification valve and then
selecting the option that says all
finally this video will of course
contain seven deadly sins manga spoilers
we are talking about the very latest in
the story so please proceed with caution
you have been warned to quickly recap
the events of
chapter 341 and started off with gold
her explaining to the sense why he
thinks that Merlin never told them about
her plan to resurrect chaos throughout
the story each of the sins had their own
wish and Merlin's wish was to revive
chaos and to resurrect Arthur as the
king of chaos but the reason why Merlin
didn't tell the sins about her plan was
because she didn't think that they would
support or understand what she was
trying to do they would have told her
that the power of chaos is too dangerous
and that she shouldn't be taking such
big risks and from everything we've seen
so far this is absolutely true the power
of chaos is extremely dangerous and
unstable just look at what Kath was able
to achieve by ingesting just a fragment
of chaos some of the sins like King feel
that Merlin used them in order to get
her wish but go their defense Marilyn
saying that she also saved the sins many
times and she waited for all their
wishes to come true before finally going
off to pursue her own wish Gotha also
emphasizes that he is not taking sides
here he considers all of the sins his
precious comrades nevertheless millio
distress is that they cannot let the
power of chaos go unchecked it is far
too dangerous and Merlin has to be held
responsible for what she's done then in
the next moment the sins can send some
strange type of magic coming from the
distance from the very place where they
had come from and where Merlin and
Arthur are still located this magic is
of course the magic of Kath Pollock who
as we know from the previous chapter
wasn't actually defeated by Arthur
instead he was able to reconstruct
himself and in so doing he attained a
new ultimate form a form that I must say
does look pretty damn cool and it is
much cooler than the previous cat forms
that we've seen so far back on the
battlefield Merlin is in the middle of
fighting Kath she is doing her best to
keep Kath away from Arthur because Kats
ultimate goal is of course to devour
Arthur Arthur pledges to defeat Kath and
he tries to cut the beast down using
Excalibur but Kath cannot be defeated by
being cut every time the monster is cut
it just regenerates its entire body
what's more when Arthur proclaims that
he is determined to protect the kingdom
of Camelot and its people Kath reveals
that Kamel
has been reduced to rubble as a result
of the latest holy war arthur is
actually able to use the power of chaos
to somehow confirm that what Kath is
saying is true
chaos powers somehow allows Arthur to
see with his own eyes that Camelot has
basically been pulverized this is an
interesting aspect of chaos power that
we haven't seen until now for some
reason chaos grants Arthur the ability
to accurately see any place of his
choosing even from a massive distance
Merlin tells Arthur that he can always
rebuild his kingdom especially now that
he possesses the power of chaos and
thankfully most of his people are safe
they managed to survive and they sought
refuge in Leonys still Arthur is
devastated because he had promised the
people of Camelot that he would restore
the kingdom but instead he allowed it to
be destroyed Kath uses Arthur's moment
of weakness to attack him and as she
tries to protect Arthur Merlin puts
herself in harm's way just as she is
about to take the full brunt of Cath's
power meliodas suddenly appears and uses
full counter to throw cat's attack back
at him Kath is seemingly torn to pieces
as a result of melioidosis full counter
along with Millie Otis all of the other
remaining sins and Elisabeth have
returned to help Merlin and Arthur
meliodas tells Merlin that she must
accept responsibility for her actions by
dedicating her life to protecting Arthur
and at the same time le oda says that
the sins bear some responsibility for
forgiving Merlin's foolishness so they
must take responsibility for protecting
her merlin is touched by this and that
is how chapter 341 ends with the sins
reunited again and working together with
Merlin to defeat the dastardly caf-pow
Luke but despite melioidosis full
counter in chapter 3 for two we see that
Kath [ __ ] is able to just regenerate
and quickly repair the physical damage
that the full counter caused Kath is
getting annoyed with the sins constantly
getting in its way of devouring Arthur
King and en wonder whether casts ability
to regenerate like this is the same type
of immortality that bond used to have
but Merlin answers that no this is
completely different thanks to the power
of chaos Kath is now being that
transcends life and death itself as his
massive body regenerates Kath
gets all philosophical on Arthur Cass
asks why Arthur is upset that his
kingdom was destroyed when that was
inevitable anyway if Camelot hadn't been
destroyed now it could have been
destroyed later by someone else or even
by a meteor everyone and everything
eventually dies people animals mountains
lakes and even gods everything dies
everything is destroyed eventually the
only thing that always remains constant
is chaos this is an interesting concept
that Kath brings up nothing physical is
permanent in this world everything ends
eventually as much as we try to preserve
things as they are as much as we try to
organize and plan everything out
perfectly we will all share the same
fate eventually one could reasonably
argue that chaos really is the only
constant in our own world as well
everything else is fleeting and
impermanent it's interesting because
even though cats and tensions are
villainous the philosophy that he is
espousing reminds me a lot of stoicism
stoic philosophers believe that we have
to accept that the world can be chaotic
and that there are certain things that
are out of our control
the Stoics teach us to accept the
inevitable and just do our best with the
things that we have control over while
never stressing out over the things that
we cannot control
change is inevitable death is inevitable
but that shouldn't be a reason to
despair
instead that should remind us to always
make the best out of every moment
because nothing is guaranteed in this
world of course that is not what Cass is
saying Kath wants Arthur to despair
but I thought that it was interesting
that this villain actually reminded me
of stoic philosophy which I greatly
appreciate after the philosophical
discussion we get an epic two-page
spread that shows caf-pow Luke attacking
the sins and I really have to praise the
art on this page it does a great job of
portraying this fight between Kass and
the sins in just two pages there is a
lot of movement in action all happening
at once and I really have to praise
knockabout and all his assistants for
this one ultimately Merlin is able to
use her incredible infinity magic to
suspend Cath's time he remains suspended
in the air motionless and his wounds are
not healing instantly as they had been
Laer Merlin says that cat's body will
remain suspended in this way for dozens
of years or even a few centuries
although he will break free eventually
and melly Otis responds by saying that
they'll cross that bridge when they get
to it Elizabeth
assures the sins that as long as they
work together they will all be fine and
they all go home happy next we see
images of Elizabeth Emily Otis finally
getting married
in the Onis with King Bartra and the
holy Knights crying tears of joy upon
seeing the two star-crossed lovers
finally getting married and yes if you
think that all of this is weird and
happening way too fast you're right but
hold on we'll get to it unfortunately
many of many Otis and Elizabeth's
friends couldn't make it because they
were busy doing other things Elaine is
pregnant and bond had to stay by her
side King and Deanna are in the fairy
realm Hawk and go through are doing
their own thing and Merlin and Arthur
are busy rebuilding Camelot okay I could
understand some of the others not coming
and bonds excuse because Elaine is
pregnant is acceptable because if she's
about to give birth any day he has to
stay by her side but under no
circumstances would I believe that Hawk
would miss Melly Otis and Elizabeth's
wedding absolutely not possible I mean
does Hawk really look like the type of
guy who would have better things to do
not likely
eventually a lot of time goes by and
bond dies of old age now that he is
mortal again and even Elizabeth is about
to die for the last time this time is an
old lady with meliodas by her side the
two of them reminisce about how it's
been a happy 3,000 years despite all the
challenges that they faced but then
suddenly a guard appears and meliodas
rushes out
well Yoda sees that calf is finally back
and he begins to slaughter the knights
of Leonys cath mocks Millie Otis because
he is now the only one facing him it's
only been a few years and all his
friends are either dead or gone Malley
Otis is enraged and he fights against
Kath but Kath keeps mocking him saying
that if Millie Otis had just let him
kill everyone back then then he wouldn't
have to go through such a protracted
period of pain and loss cath tries to
convince me Otis that he is alone and
that everything is pointless because
chaos is the only constant and
eventually everyone disappears and
nothing really man
but meliodas refuses to accept this
remembering all his friends he exclaims
that their bonds will never go away and
in that moment a shocked sweaty meliodas
returns to the battlefield from the
beginning of the chapter where the sins
and Elizabeth are still there with him
they are still young and Kath is there
two seemingly freed from Merlins magic
so basically it was all a prank bro but
let's continue
Meli otis wonders if he had just
experienced the powerful hallucination
or if it was real but Arthur tells him
that what meliora saw was just one of
many possible futures it was neither
real nor a hallucination just one
potential outcome of the battle at least
that's how I understand it Arthur
declares that they must find a way to
defeat caf-pow Luke once and for all
kath says that it's futile because
Arthur will inevitably be swallowed by
him and then Kaz will become fully
unified with chaos and swallow
everything and in that moment
Arthur appears to have some sort of
Epiphany he says that he's figured it
out he's figured out a way to defeat
Kath and that is where the chapter ends
without an explanation about how exactly
Arthur intends to defeat Kath or what
kind of breakthrough he just had this
ending of the chapter really left me
wondering what Arthur meant when he said
that he had found a way to defeat Kath
since at the time Kath was talking about
swallowing Arthur and everything else
does this mean that Arthur is planning
to swallow Kath instead and take back
all the chaos power that Kath took from
him this seems kind of silly but with
all the talk of devouring my first
thought was maybe Arthur is about to
flip the script and have some calf
casserole but the more likely
explanation is that the crazy possible
future that meliodas experienced gave
Arthur the idea to use the power of
chaos itself to somehow seal kaif away
perhaps Arthur will use chaos to send
Kath into a different reality or into a
different future or perhaps Arthur will
use the power of chaos to banish Kath
into another realm or realm from which
he will be incapable of harming anyone
in Britannia this could potentially tie
into what I mentioned in the previous
video about the realms being separated
just as the intro of the anime
prophesized trapping Kathryn on
different
could stop him from causing any more
chaos here in Britannia and of course
separating all the warring clans into
separate realms could end the holy wars
once and for all
although this would also mean that all
of our favourite characters who come
from different clans would have to be
separated as well which would suck a lot
and this brings me to the ending of the
seven deadly sins could the news be true
could the manga really be ending in just
four or five chapters and if so how
could it possibly end in a satisfying
way this chaos arc is seemingly just
getting started and there are a ton of
unsolved mysteries still lingering so
personally I do not think that a
satisfying ending in such a short period
of time is even possible sure they could
potentially defeat Cass in that time and
go live happily ever after but that
doesn't give us closure about the
supreme deity it doesn't give us closure
about Eskin or sacrifice and it
certainly doesn't give us full closure
about Merlin and why she did all the
things that she had done I mean are we
really going to stick to Merlin just
being upset that she couldn't hook up
with Melly Otis so she channeled all her
romantic frustration into magical
curiosity and it was that curiosity
alone which made her dedicate her life
to resurrecting the power of chaos if
that ends up being the case then
Merlin's backstory is by far the worst
and least compelling backstory out of
all the sins I certainly hope that we
will still get more about Merlin's
backstory and that we are going to get a
better explanation about her true
intentions if we don't I will be greatly
disappointed and let's face it cath
Pollock as cool as he is now in his new
form does not feel like a final villain
by any stretch of the imagination the
only way that our real ending is
possible in the next few chapters is if
we learned that the seven deadly sins
manga is ending only to make room for
some sort of direct continuation some
sort of seventh of these sins
Shibu then that will directly continue
the story and that will finally answer
all of the many unsolved mysteries in
the series I really don't see any other
way to get a satisfying ending either we
will need a lot more than four or five
chapters or we will need a direct
continuation of the story even if it is
under another name but please let me
know what you guys think is the story
really ending in just a few more
chapters and if so what kind of end
could we possibly be getting can you see
the ending being satisfying or good in
any way or would it have to be extremely
rushed and anticlimactic hit me up with
your feedback down in the comments below
if you enjoyed this video you want us to
keep the seven deadly sins content going
please leave a like to let me know it
really does help and if you happen to be
new to anime uproar or if you just
haven't subscribed yet please subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications if you want to be
notified and you don't want YouTube to
bury our videos you have to go through
the trouble of clicking the bell and
selecting the option that says all you
can also hit me up on Twitter and
Instagram at anime uproar I want to give
a big thank you to all of our anime out
pro patrons for supporting our work and
making these videos possible with all
the constant problems on YouTube patron
support is more important than ever
thank you guys so much
first and foremost a special thank you
to our the one tier patrons the ones who
rise above all other clans including in
grata alone Adam the world stealers the
school bus
Tyson Karina acquired respect and Pat a
heffa and I can't forget our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
Kings eldred's fitted ala beat alpha do
Anatoli Cassatt's ki on hell Cruz team
Sparky 65 cricket XP Rohan Kapoor
Jessica Maloney Emperor otaku Timothy
Vargas Sean dark Joe Stanton JCCC waka
Barrie Gucci and Jessica Calif all if
you enjoy our videos and you think that
they provide value for you consider
supporting us on patreon even a single
dollar will give you access to our
patron exclusive discord and your name
will appear in our videos along with
these legendary people as always thank
you guys so much for watching and until
next time see us bass cowboys
[Music]